hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round five of this
year's European team Chess Championship
it is Daniel vocaturo versus Yan F
Forest board one uh Italy versus
Netherlands and it's quite a short game
but quite an interesting one and it
features a very sneaky Queen trap that
you guys will have a chance to figure
out on your own so let's check it out
Danielle has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 uh we have Pawn to
C6 D4 D5 the caroan defense is on the
board Knight C3 uh D captures on e4
Knight captures and Knight to F6 we have
Knight captures on F6 e captures on F6
and now uh Bishop to E3 a few hours ago
I played a game that I uploaded um uh
will be probably uh probably watchable
in some two hours where I continue with
Pont to C3 and it was a very interesting
game for those of you who are enjoying
the rapid action on leeches uh but here
we have Bishop to E3 and in that game I
mention mention that I always go for a
C3 line against this car canera because
there's a gamean shish to D that played
against Magnus Carlson in the Norway
chess 2020 and he won an incredible game
so I kind of uh you know thought that it
was it was appropriate to to play that
if if the great Magnus fell to it so
might my opponents but here we have a
very moresque setup here Danielle will
go for Bishop E3 Bishop D3 Queen F3 and
queens side Castle so incredibly rapid
development uh Bishop to D6 Bishop to D3
and now Knight to D7 uh the standard REM
maneuvering of the Knight to D7 to f8
and then to G6 or E6 uh we have Queen to
F3 and now Knight to f8 and here uh
there are some games where Knight to E2
was played but here we have Queens side
castles and it is now already as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so uh Jordan goes for Bishop D6 very
rare that you will see in top level
chess both of the Bishops set up this
way C4 as the A2 Pawn is is hanging so
Pawn to C4 you could also play King to
B1 it's always a question do you want to
waste a move on that or not Knight to G6
and now Pawn to H4 going right after
that Knight with Pawn to H5 so Queen to
D7 trying to win The Exchange here uh
but now Pawn to H5 so what's the idea
can you just win the exchange here well
not really the king is still in the
center of the board uh here uh Jordan
does go for Bishop to G4 but now Queen
to E4 with check Knight to E7 makes
sense you want to block check as your
knight is also hanging on G6 and now
Bishop to E2 blocking with Bishop to F5
attacking Daniel's queen queen to H4 and
now uh interestingly uh we have to also
look at the aspect of aspect of time
here Jordan spent not even 10 minutes
reaching this position on move 15 and
vocaturo spent uh some 45 minutes so uh
he he's really trying to play against
well Jordan who is already in Elite
player as and a much higher rated
opponent uh but it it's costing him a
lot of time so here Pawn to B5 it's a
standard um standard maneuver in in this
caroan where White Castle Queen set and
has C4 you want to open up the attack
towards White's King and of course Pawn
to G4 going after the bishop and now
Jordan plays Bishop T6 but now it comes
with tempo as the C4 Pawn is hanging so
the best way to play this and this is if
you really let the engine crunch the
numbers and black is much better here
white is actually already in survival
mode uh if C5 for example is played
Bishop to C7 yes you've prevented black
from opening up the queen side but now
the8 you Pawn is hanging you play King
to B1 then Queen to D5 is coming you
have to play B3 then already A5 and it's
a very very scary position to defend for
white uh but in the game uh vocaturo
said nope uh we are not defending this
we are going for an allout attack on the
king Side Pawn to G5 f captures and G5
Queen captures going after the G pawn
and now Jordan just opens up the B file
we have B captures and C4 Queen captures
on G7 Rook to G8 attacking the queen and
even Queen captures on H7 so now
Danielle has created a pass Pawn uh But
Here Comes Pawn to F5 attacking the
queen only Square for the queen is Queen
to H6 so this is what he plays but now
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Jordan uh while I give you a
couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the White Queen is trapped on H6 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight to D5 this is what
ordan played and now you see that there
is no defense against Bishop to f8 the
queen it's interesting uh you you can't
even move anything to make room for the
Queen the H Pawn cannot move the bishop
cannot move this the entire diagonal is
covered if you could get the Queen to D2
okay maybe you could continue uh there's
just no Square Knight to F3 was played
sort of going for Knight to E5 to attack
the black queen but it changes nothing
here ordan just played Bishop to f8 and
he was in this position on move 22 that
Daniel vocaturo resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
very very interesting game brilliant
game by ordan he spent uh interestingly
also Daniel uh was left with 26 minutes
on the clock at the end of the game and
Jordan spent 26 minutes for for the
entire game uh so also very interesting
but yeah here we resign because even if
you play Knight E5 and it's your only
move anything else you play you have to
give up the queen uh but for those of
you who like it when I finish the games
yeah you will just capture the queen and
now after Knight captures on D7 the
problem is uh the king is on the same
diagonal as the bishop but Bishop
captures on E3 is nice you could play of
course this and it will still be winning
after King captures on D7 but now comes
Bishop captures on C4 and after Knight
captures on E3 attacking the rook and
the bishop there's Bishop D3 attacking D
F5 Bishop so if you capture a bishop
captures on F5 comes with check so we'll
have to play Bishop D6 and then the Rook
moves rook dt1 and the game continues
where black will just be up a full
Knight of course completely winning okay
white is up a pawn the H Pawn is um a
little bit dangerous but eventually you
will win this however you don't have to
allow any of this after in this line we
don't have to play Bishop captures on E3
we just play Knight captures on E3 of
course we allow the monster Bishop pair
to remain active on these diagonals and
after something like Knight to F6 giving
up the exchange here King E7 Knight
captures Rook captures and now Rook to
D2 uh there's not all that much you can
do here with white the the king's
absolutely getting destroyed here let's
say Bishop E4 attacks The Rook Bishop to
F3 you can even trade here not a problem
Bishop captures on F3 Rook to E1 will
win back material Bishop to E4 F
captures on E3 and now just Rook to G G3
and uh there there's really no move here
you can defend the pawn but now Bishop
D3 chases away the rook and once The
Rook moves you capture the pawn here
King moves and now uh pretty much
anything can be played but um there's
nothing for white to try here if the
Rook ever moves the back rank which
which it can't really do uh this would
be Checkmate as all of the squares here
are covered in front of the white king
and there is zero counterplay here for
white Black's plan is very simple black
will simply Advance this Pawn to Victory
and that's it white has nothing to say
about this as F3 F2 and F1 are covered
so you will play just uh you know few
more moves and after five moves white
resigns this so White's only counter
place to push the pawn uh but of course
black is much faster once you stop this
King to G8 and you put a king on h8
that's it there's no more there's no
more counterplay here for white it's not
a matter only a matter of pushing the F
Pawn so of course many ways to win this
but after Bishop to f8 vocaturo said all
right I've had enough great game uh sir
and uh I resign uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by Jordan beautiful
miniature only 22 moves in the caroan so
you know no wonder everyone has hates
playing against the caroan and if you
want to see caran played on a much much
lower level first link in the
description below will be not now but in
some two hours when it becomes active my
game that I played in the caroan
variation uh so yeah thank you all I
mean I would like to thank the the kbu
chess club um Chen bohu and siik Nick
Donald Duncan Parker Andreas rosental
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the European Team
Championship until it finishes thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day